Alexa how do I add something to my
shopping list according to wiki how to
make a shopping list that's not what I
meant
he thinks you've researched no I meant
like dish soap or shampoo or this is
actually a very useful thing if you
didn't know how to make a shopping list
but it's not to do with my shopping list
piece of paper on your phone Alexa stop
today I think we're talking about well
voice interfaces I think and the Amazon
echo which uses the Alexa service which
I'm sure a lot of viewers will have will
have used or have won or something like
that and we've got it on muted a minute
haven't we yeah just because you know it
would be quite irritating if it wasn't
on meat especially talking about Alexa
without actually addressing Alexa in our
studies actually the the people who are
using our devices have to work out ways
to talk about it without addressing it
so how'd she you have become something
you got to do in essence we say
something like question ask for
information perhaps you want to play a
game or something like that and the
device hears it and then it responds and
you know gives us the information we
want perhaps add something to our
shopping list or whatever it might be
you know gives you directions you know
going to some place on the map whatever
and that's essentially what happens so
why don't you ask something through
Alexa
Alexa what is computer file the
definition of computer file is computer
science a file maintained in computer
readable form question no well that's a
tricky one because there's ambiguity
there right because I have asked about
what I'm talking about can be too far as
one word and it's taking it as being two
words right yeah yeah so that so we
think we're in one situation but the
Alexa thinks we're in another situation
so and now it's just triggered again
thanks a lot Alexa stop okay I'll use it
in the description I'm going to go
through kind of some of the basic things
that happen but obviously it's much more
complex
this if we give the example of kind of
thinking about a shopping list so with
with a lack so you can maintain a
shopping list you can add stuff remove
stuff whatever it might be
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
say something like you know Alexa could
you tell me what's on my shopping list
so this is us saying something she knows
as a smileyface
beach bubble draw a speech bubble you
know this is a wave form effectively
when it's picked up by the device so you
know sound the sound wave what the
device is going to do is going to take
this stuff and it's going to run it
through automatic speech recognition ASR
and this is detecting what was said
essentially the first thing the ASR is
doing but it's local to the device is
picking up the wake word Alexa the wake
word is the first thing that's being
detected so there is some kind of
onboard speech recognition going on on
the device itself to work out when
Alexis being said now the rest of this
stuff the kind of that could you tell me
what's on my shopping list that's being
shipped off to the cloud for speech
recognition being done on the rest of
this sentence that we're saying to the
device and that's kind of passing
through these very sophisticated complex
deep learning models you know this is
one thing one of the major innovations
of these devices is actually having ASR
that works you know pretty well and not
saying it works for everyone but it
works well for a lot of people at least
compared to kind of how things used to
be
so it's shipping all this stuff off into
the cloud you know could you tell me
what's on my shopping list
it's transcribing those into bitter text
essentially so we've got this bit of
text that says could you tell me what's
on my shopping list and now we need to
do something with that text we need to
make sense of it in some way and one of
the first stages that it goes through is
something called natural language
processing an LP or natural language
understanding and this is taking this
text and breaking it up into things that
are meaningful from the point of view of
the the system essentially from the
point of view of the Alexa service and
that's not going to be everything so
some stuffs going to get chucked away so
I would guess and this is just my guess
that the things that's happening in the
in the natural language processing a
natural language understanding elements
of the of the kind of the cycle if you
like things like shopping lists that's
something that it knows about perhaps
you know could you not really
necessarily that
useful so probably being chucked away
that's commerce almost like a politeness
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
so it's kind of redundant from the point
of view this system although you know if
we talk about actual conversation and
talk it's certainly not redundant in
actual talk it's meaningful probably
something like tell me is is a
significant phrase again that's being
parsed out and noticed by the parser and
maybe some of the other bits about you
know my shopping list rather than you
know Sean's shopping list or something
like that so it's pausing these things
out that sentence is starting to be
decomposed into things that are
meaningful from the system point of view
after this stage what we're now looking
at is you know we've got to do something
with these bits of sentence that we've
passed and this is obviously a
simplification I'm sure there are lots
of other architectures around there and
they're different to this one but I'm
just going to go with kind of what I
know then there's something called a
dialog manager and this thing is taking
all those bits the parse bits we know we
know something about you know subject
and the object and whatever it might be
in this case you know that the
meaningful thing might be shopping list
and the kind of command to tell me and
the fact that it's my shopping list not
someone else's and the dialogue manager
is taking all these bits and pieces and
it's got to come up with the next
response sorry a response to it in this
case it might be you know there's
nothing currently on your shopping list
or whatever Alexa actually says as a
result of that that command so you know
it's got to generate something but in
the course of doing so the dialogue
manager has got to do all sorts of other
stuff it's got to kind of put you
perhaps in some kind of conversational
flow or like a state it's going to be
looking at kind of what stage you're at
in the you know current assumed from the
system's point if you assumed assumed
conversational you know state might be
and then it's got to draw on other
resources as well with a shopping list
it's kind of something about Amazon
services come into play so you know
where it's storing this information I'm
no idea where it's storing it in the
cloud somewhere but it's retrieving that
information about what's actually on the
shopping list this is flight data it
might be other stuff that we're looking
up like perhaps of web resources you
know if you asked about information
about a particular topic it's got to
scrape that stuff off the web or grab it
somehow
and it's got to feed that into the
dialogue manager which is doing this
kind of generating net was next
responses so it might kind of simplified
version there's something about the kind
of state we're in in the conversational
flow perhaps there's more questions that
the device is going to ask after this or
whatever it might be to clarify things
or whatever there's some other resources
that it might be drawing on to feed data
into the response and then it's
generating response which might be as I
said you know you know you have no items
on your shopping list which is going no
that's kind of what it's coming out with
but then that's just a kind of you know
text output it's got to say this so the
next stage is to do text-to-speech so
it's going to generate speech based on
what this text is there's a whole load
of complex stuff around speech
generation
you know there's a whole whole area of
research about how you actually go about
doing that which is again very
sophisticated in complex and then it
comes out the device the echo as the
response and so we hear it the really
heavy stuff is this stuff here like the
ASR stuff here the speech recognition of
stuff that's where you need a whole ton
of data and quite you know significant
models that you've learned which then
you know you put an input which is these
bits of audio and you get output nuts
you know which is these bits of text
which are which are which map you know
there's a notice obviously a confidence
associated with that that's a whole you
know massive complex area so that's the
stuff that really relies on um you know
these kind of significant computing
power also you know that the parsing
they're going to be wanting to update
all the time so that has to be a service
but yeah in terms of the text-to-speech
as they want to kind of update it and
change it and pushing out updates to the
device be a problem so that might be why
you you would actually be shipping audio
but something we could we could find out
or be told by yeah by commenters I'm
sure
the reason for doing this rather
artificial example is to say oh dear
does this matter we have got a sentence
that makes perfect sense to us one
picture of Sean right so maybe what
miles gets put over here near me which
is not so good but we'll get to that and
then you'll put over here like this